[Music]
together again the theme of this year's
calgary stampede an apt one after two
years spectators in their western best
able to line the streets for the annual
kickoff parade
marshall this year with some big star
power kevin costner who often plays a
cowboy on screen saddling up to lead the
way the idea that kovit has reminded us
sometimes that things can be taken from
us in a wink of an eye
and to understand we can come back out
and celebrate this parade this this
yearly thing that's been happening for
almost 100 years
or over 100 years
but it hasn't happened here since 2019
there was a scale down stampede in 2021
one of the first events to move forward
since covet 19. this is general public
free admission but this year all
restrictions are gone and the tourism
industry is ready to come back big in
some ways the the city really wants this
and this is really important for the
city our tourism industry has been hit
hard by the pandemic this is a really
great opportunity to get back to work
the stampede says it's not expecting to
break any attendance records this year
focusing instead on getting back into
its usual groove but around the city all
is not quite back to normal yet and some
pandemic caused problems remain catering
companies they're tough on staff
lighting companies sound companies
they're tight on staff so we've actually
to turn down three events move them to
later in the year
because we just couldn't find the team
still plenty of parties are going ahead
and visitors are ready to take it all in
she's from italy and just visiting us
here in calgary she's my sister it just
looks amazing so far just being with
everyone she wants the cockroach all the
crazy food i'm really looking forward to
the grandstand show i think that it's
sounding really good this year the hats
and boots belt buckles and beer are back
heather urex west global news calgary